not gonna lie to you I do love that song
sabotage by the Beastie Boys I love it
as tapping my foot Star Trek beyond what
reviews only like a week and a half late
now mcdale so Star Trek beyond is the
third Star Trek movie among the JJ
Abrams rebooted Star Trek franchise with
JJ Abrams did not direct this one this
is directed by Justin Lin who we have
seen makes exciting action movies now
he's applying that to Star Trek in a
special way Star Trek beyond the crew of
the enterprise have been doing their
deep space exploration mission for a
couple years now James C Kirk's kind of
feeling like well where does it end I'm
starting to feel like why are we doing
this and all hell breaks loose they get
stranded on this planet where there's
this [ __ ] named Crowell I wait crawl
not crawl alright crawl is capturing the
crew of the enterprise and he has a
master scheme of destruction we don't
know what it is yet but a Kirk has to
stop it in a surprisingly fulfilling
Star Trek film I mean by the time the
third film rolls around in any franchise
you start thinking like alright when's
it gonna lose steam JJ Abrams isn't
doing it anymore he's not directing it
anyways they're like is this going to be
as good and I was surprised at how much
I enjoyed this movie first of all the
crew the enterprise they all still got
it this movie actually concentrates on
certain relationships and friendships
more than it has in the past cause this
new character Jayla they've run into
down on that planet she helps him out I
really liked her yes for that reason and
also because I thought she was a cool
character to his kick-ass she was
relevant she was helpful perfect and
Kroll was a good villain ever since the
first JJ Abrams Star Trek movie is like
alright that was a weak villain how
about we not do that again bringing in
Cumberbatch for the sequel is a surefire
way to fix that problem but in this one
alright now we don't have Cumberbatch we
have another actor I don't know if it's
a spoiler to tell you who plays him so
I'm not going to but that was a solid
antagonist right there but the biggest
thing this movie impressed me on is how
it's an exciting action movie for sure
but it also kind of brings it back to
what you loved about old-school Star
Trek the biggest gripe I've heard ever
since JJ Abrams did his whole like reset
button is the fact that it's now an
action franchise it doesn't have any of
the heart it doesn't have any of the
life lessons that the old Star Trek
series had they were known for this
movie actually throws some of those
nuggets out there I mean when the
villains talking with Kirk Kirk throws
something back at him you're like that's
relevant to the humanity
and that's what Star Trek is known for
power ops my man props for bringing that
back I can't give enough props for that
as someone who grew up on and loved Star
Trek and Star Wars yeah
before Abrams directed both you could
still love both I thought that was a
solid throwback can't stress that enough
and the action is really exciting also
props to the heart and the fields in
here man just character wise there were
more than a couple of moments where
you're like I really feel the bonding
among these characters I really feel
like that character is really
contemplating his [ __ ] and in that
really nostalgic moment that also hits
you hits him and you connect with the
character now and is just successfully
done the bummer that this movie runs
into is I feel like it was such a
successful throwback to old Trek and
wild still incorporating new Trek style
it doesn't really break any new ground I
mean even there's this big reveal in the
movie and as you're watching the movie
you're like I saw that coming 10 parsecs
away it's pretty formulaic Enterprise
goes out Enterprise gets its ass kicked
now there's trouble Kirk needs to stop
it and here we are
it's reliably entertaining but there's
no real wow factor there's no real thing
that makes you go oh whoa I didn't see
that coming guys in the end Star Trek
beyond was entertaining it's great to
see the crew back is pretty formulaic
it's pretty predictable but it is very
entertaining I loved it and it was a
successful merging a new Star Trek
action Star Trek and the sentimentality
of old Trek that hopefully appeases both
groups of fans I will certainly say Star
Trek beyond is worth watching and worth
buying on blu-ray
alright guys so Star Trek beyond have
you seen it what did you think about it
or with your favorite and least favorite
Star Trek movies whatever they are
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you